je me trouve rue de belfort à chalon sur
saône à quelques minutes du centre ville
c'est ici que la bourgogne a accueilli
la semaine dernière à sa première
boutique de revente de cannabis légal
vous le voyez derrière moi besten shops
est une boutique d'une dizaine de mètres
carrés à l'intérieur le client peut
trouver du cannabis 10 et bd c'est à
dire sans la molécule thc nocives pour
l'organisme
ce cannabis cbd se trouve sous
différentes formes en fleurs pour les
tisanes en huile ou en cristaux à mettre
sous la langue ou encore sous forme de
bonbons son patron n'a pas souhaité
parler à notre caméra mais il décrit son
commerce comme une boutique de bien-être
nous avons posé la question à ses
clients voici leurs réponses
j'ai entendu parler justement des vertus
médicinales de cbd et ma grand mère elle
a un traitement lourd à base de morphine
tout ça parce qu'elle a eu un problème
d'un cancer et on voulait essayer parce
qu'on nous a dit que ça faisait passer
le traitement moi je suis dépendant
depuis quelques années j'ai fait
plusieurs chevreuils qui n'ont pas du
tout marché et franchement j'espère que
ça ça a marché parce que ça permettrait
de reprendre une vie normale d'avoir un
salaire et un travail 24 heures sur 24
j'ai les jambes qui me brûle et qui ont
tendance à trembler tout seul avec des
mouvements de raidisseurs l'avantagent
de cbd ça agit sur l'endorphine et coupe
la douleur et les tremblements de la
jambe en permanence depuis son ouverture
il y a une semaine la boutique attire
beaucoup de curieux des jeunes aussi qui
ne sont pourtant pas la cible de ce
commerce
il faut dire que ce cannabis sans thc
coûte cher 50 euros les 2 grammes et
demi soit au moins deux fois plus que
sur le marché parallèle
ici c'est bien le bien-être et
l'apaisement des douleurs qui est
recherché pas d'inquiétude donc pour le
jeune public
selon cette spécialiste en addictologie
produit à l'évasion à la défonce
normalement il doit comporter au pire 0
2 % de thc donc lequel à bibione les pas
celui qui est le plus recherché parmi
les jeunes qui vont plutôt être dans une
consommation plaisir aux consommations
évasion de consommation conviviale
basten shop compte ouvrir d'autres
boutiques de ce type dans les jours à
venir notamment à dijon
dans le même temps la ministre de la
santé envisage de revoir la législation
pour fermer ces commerces
à suivre donc